la première mur laponie vous le savez on
a certains qui avaient mal dormi alors
j'ai décidé d'offrir à ceux qui avaient
plus mal dormi un palace alors au début
ça se passe bien vous allez voir j'ai
peu à peu ça va se dégrader
évidemment
[Musique]
qui a senti qu'il avait vraiment mal
dormir
gilles oui et mathieu mathieu qui
avaient dormi avec jean-michel son ami
de toujours
est ce que c'est bien passé ben non
ehrhoff mais j'avais vu ça de ma vie
comme toi tu dormais avec gide way et
gilles ne souhaite plus dormir avec mon
nom j'ai dû fuir parce qu'il ya des
odeurs pestilentielles qui se dégage je
suis vraiment pas sensible je me plains
jamais mais là ça pue mais tellement
j'ai dû aller dans le couloir alors
alors gill et mathieu g les bonnes
nouvelles pour vous allez dormir
ensemble ce soir vous allez dormir dans
un petit palace
donc je vais vous demander d'aller
préparer vos affaires tous les deux
enfin vous préparez vous à faire et vous
allez dormir tous les deux tranquille
soldes 5 étoiles palace c'est au dessus
chaque étoile istres 2 1 oui mais
justement c'est le seul truc c'est que
vous serez ensemble programme sur vos
gueules de coûts allez allez allez
cherchez vous à faire ça c'est gentil la
foule est compacte avec toi du salut les
rats gars marveaux mille pattes
j'aurais payé importe quelle faille
japon toujours fait défaut
j'ai piloté sociale mathieu et gilles
benest mes chiens balas tient pas là
vous allez voir fait génial merci un
série tales où la voiture
franchement je pense les chéris vous
allez être contents d'abord ils se ruent
vers pas bonne et on y va parce que si
on va dire dont les palaces
on va y aller à pied vous avez un rêve
pour moi pas je voulais que friends
valises pajot bien ça me paraît la
moindre des choses si la bataille
d'alger prix minimum parce que tout sera
là bas j'imagine je provoque alisme
vas-y vas-y maxime tu seras là bas jean
tu leur donnes rama marques que gm pour
les crèmes les soins inquiète pas
le spa ce que je veux je veux un soin
visage mais après je vous dirai comment
c'était un mariage et c'est un room
service
ah oui ce soir au gala des arts vivants
par contre le shérif c'est un soir elle
faisait bien avec la soirée c'est le
généreux va tutoyer son visage se sera
pas de trop pour toi vous faire alors
nous on est déjà arrivé belle entrée là
n'entrez pas mal entrer là bas dit je
leur ai dit au premier mais c'est une
blague
québec c est génial moi j'ai envie d
être et ben vas-y vous êtes invités à
s'asseoir s'est livré aux anges c'est
sûr ça t'amuse si fénoir aller plus haut
du dos et au cou qui a fait ça c'est
qu'ainsi s'est fait tremper dans l'amont
tu as ta douce voilà c'est non
c'est plein d'ombrés c'est pas drôle là
préfèrent encore gagné ses surnoms bêtes
ça tombe jamais aulas les copains bon
léger la clé blague contrairement au
sexe plus c'est court mieux c'est
reposez vous êtes malade ou quoi remonte
mois le sac à dos par en dessous
le bassin top les îles oui bon là non
c'est mon pantalon sa censure par oui tu
t'es mis du bon côté et moi j'ai mis
d'accueil
mon dieu mais si on m'avait dit que tu
pas que dans le top 2 des personnes que
je maîtrise le plus dans l'émission
offrait une autre bague au doigt c'est
quand même quelque chose si tu as froid
tu viens quand même pas y'a pas de
soucis y'a pas de télé rien du coup les
mutins raconte mon histoire
parle-moi au nom avec palmes un truc qui
m'intéresse pas de [ __ ] cas cumulés
tous les cauchemars 21 spaf à tous
attention abbas est vraiment je te
préviens je crois que là on en est rendu
même ça ça pourrait m'intéresser à aa
je vais raconter nos nuits raconte moi
votre encore à tous parce que je
reconnais qu'il ya un truc qui bien que
toi et qu'en tu parles je m'endors si je
m'endors vraiment demain l'horreur c'est
que j'aimerais bien commencé mais
l'autre c'est au réveil te regarder au
public ferait partie le mot lève tôt -
lot beat la loupe finlandaise je vais
être novès que cyril c'est qu'un boycott
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]